[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it is time for Jack
Reacher episode six Jack Jack sixer Jack shoot six
shooter six shooting Jack oh yeah boom we got
some we got one in there leave a like on this
video ladies and gentlemen that'd be very much
appreciated also subscribe click the notification
Bell get notified when I reaction for Jack heads
up 7even up is up on the channel and thank you
to prepper Jack prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights who's your favorite member of the
110th though leave it down below we should ask
a question when the reaction is happening that
way they know to answer then cuz they probably
skipped over to this part that's how we create
engagement H I learn some new every full length
re action watch along we seek with your own copy
of Jack Reacher available for super sex rejects
over at our patreon page we also cover several
things over there exclusive with highlights and
watch Longs included I'm ready to watch this are
you I am so ready but before that tell us in the
comments what is your favorite's your favorite the
one what do you think they used hmx hmx could be2
but hmx is a more readily available explosive who
cares what they used I'm more interested in who
used it Swan Swan did it give it up I'm really
the only one here that's going to say it Swan
hired by Swan he was going to get paid by swan
he got his ass blown halfway across the street
by Swan Swan had a good reason all right I'm not
going to assume Swan's dirty in an investigation
assumptions kill so the military grade Munitions
bomb squad Farm remnants of a trip wired Rigg
IED what are you doing at my favorite pot kids
play here well what we do know is they plan was
to have you all killed in the bone yard and then
take out the Assassins here no Loose Ends bodies
just the snipers the pal Swan wasn't there uhoh
so he's innocent a [__] yeah you call me on my
phone where okay send me the address someone in
the comments said how he' look like uh Kingpin and
he plays Murdoch's father in the Daredevil movie
I think oh damn it's actually kingpin's father
in the Netflix series get him right still cool
though cool cool fact there's someone I need to
talk to try not to leave any dead bodies behind
this time they're going to immediately go kill
some dead bodies was making a reference to all
movies yeah I C it nothing in here boss it looks
like she dumped this thing and took off if I were
her I'd hit the head and grab a snack first and
then pay off all these parking citations she got
her kid a drink in a dog and bought a burner
phone with cash keep the change she was in a
rush didn't have time for change Jack rusher
can you zoom in a little I can pop it in but
a lot of the details may be lost wow realism is
playing a Nintendo switch if we knew a gamertag
we could track the IP address to her device oh
my God the gamer shit's coming back do it yes
she had a switch at Marlo's house every detail
counts I'll take these and a Clark Bar call back
man love to see it add it to the national debt un
like the national debt it never has to be repaid
that's the truth suit jacket Reacher like him
this is my vehicle is there a problem assume her
identity just the uh Commonwealth of Pennsylvania
doesn't permit objects to hang in the rear viw
the rental car company put that there and uh not
so familiar with your traffic regulations I will
remove it in all due haste along with your head
maybe you can find the grace to give me a pass
on the ticket just give you a warning forgive me
I thought you said no ticket official warnings
still need to be written up Sir if I could have
your license it'll take me maybe 2 minutes to
run it and then you're on your way assume her
identity slice her her throat give her plastic
surgery oh that sounds like Terminator 2 music
I'll be right back with this doctor it's like
liquid Terminator stuff and the season has liquid
Terminator in it he's going to show up right
behind them both please run an interstate check
on Colorado driver's license c17 that's a Sinister
shot yeah the dash cam copy that 5 r41 stand by
okay doc we'll have you out of here short yeah
uh memory cards man we have an on Dr a victim of a
homicide Rob in Colorado proceed with caution back
up his honest way what a reversal in real life
a white guy yeah killing the Black hop a guy who
could pass instead of a white cop killing a black
civilian yes true commentary political commentary
people actually play these things well you should
try one you're like a first- person shooter I am
a first person shooter KN that was coming it's
a great line Jane's tag is plain Jane 777 I log
into my own account and play until she gets back
online going to need some gamer fuel G fuel some G
fuel get some G fuel look at that is that promo
code save 20% got to wait for Jane to get her
game on well until then I'm going to some sh ey
Jack sleeper again it's an oldie but a ky get in
there Dixon get in there get some shut eye with
Jack yeah sleeps like a vampire Jack dreamer V
preacher I'm so turned on right now leave
the room sorry we've been attacked by
bikers shot at by Hitman and almost blown
up need to put a m LLY I've got some pent
up tension and I wore my nice bra
I know you've got this rule sleep
when you can but it's not that firm of a
rule I can think of something else firm
though best episode you love to see it oh my God
what was the one in the bed that I said oh oh no
I said we going use it later damn it oh where is
it it'll come back it'll come back by the end of
the episode said it in a review section to use
later D oh smack that ass Reacher little late
for a drop it is everything okay can I come in
of course of course come in sack Reacher sack in
the sack Reacher there you go we got there what
the hell happened at that Cemetery word is some
hitters were trying to take out fr's wife so I
guess she was wrapped up in what he was doing
huh you know that's not true I know you saw that
Reacher in his team when they went to Boston and I
know you're working for those guys at New Age why
are you confronting him like this in the middle
of the night you were a wet behind the ear Punk
and you didn't know which side of your gun the
bullets came out you come in my house and you talk
this [__] to me amazing how much he's progressed
two people knew that reach and his team went to
Boston you and me and I didn't sell them out to
get jumped so who did Yeah Carl Riner who did it
look the head of security from a new age that Lon
that's right he came to me when you started
poking around the the France's murder uhoh he
backed up a truckload of cash and all he wanted
to know is what you were finding out where the
investigation was heading he just wanted updates
it's it just updates yes that's it after 9/11
your NYPD and you're aiding a betting terrorist
he watch your dad you are suling the greatest
police force in the world you're spitting on the
grave of everybody who died that day hey hey yeah
I lost more friends that morning than you'll
ever have in your goddamn life it's really good
seamwork yeah D langon is a businessman he saw a
play and he took it these are crooked cops these
are bading people yeah I've known guys like him
you know guys like him and your father definitely
knew guys like him this guy's like Serpico man
yeah what are you going to do when you find out
that they lied to you and don't ever bring up my
father again yeah I knew him well I think about
him all the time and what a good man he was
you don't deserve to say his name that good
man is 6 ft underground I don't want to go out
that way and neither should you I'm not going
to be a good man to honor his memory all right
they paid me they'll pay you take the Goddamn
money he doesn't take envelopes nope you didn't
know my father and you sure as hell don't know
me yeah buddy business oh man no now I'm worried
for his life ain't nothing nothing just business
oh Brian depa split Diop threr look at the kilos
coming in this week I keep getting words she's
a villain yeah me too said it since the second
episode Jo yeah I don't want to believe it but I
am afraid the Colonel's promotion's going through
is going to be stationed in South Korea at a base
right near the demilitarized zone waiting for the
shoe to drop ense there's no way a drug operation
that happened right under his nose is going to be
publicized in a huge bust it's not a good look why
is this bad got share the truth cuz the truth
is going to be concealed operation kaido will
be shut down got it this is [__] don't let our
friendship affect your judgment we don't have a
friendship we have a familiarity this is what will
go into your report five misdemeanor charges for
drug use only no charges for dealing conspiracy
or misappropriation of military resources one
defendant will do timing the break four will get
probation all will receive honorable discharges
that's it wow wonder he doesn't want to be part of
this military anymore yeah same what I signed up
for what's going through your mind right now how
the last big case we all had together how it all
went to [__] at the end and you're worried how
this one's going to end part of it which part this
part Swan you fixated man I think he's showcasing
a lot more of his internal pain this season you've
done so much for me me for all of us he trained
us so when the time comes I'll do it I'll kill
Swan of course you will she's got truths to cover
up that's true pull trigger soon as Jane started
gaming she sucks by the way I had tech services
in my office track her down got us a location an
hour away I followed my nose happy P She should
have used the informal too Jack French speaker is
this feeling more like a crime drama now this
isn't your fault Marlo I remember when I left
Thomas it's never easy that window's getting
shattered at some point why are my sprinklers
going off in the middle of winter I noticed that
too jump through the window I'm going to fire that
grounds keeper yeah I'll be right back someone
go fire on you he knows why it's going off it's
clearly a sign a signal to leave evacuate meet
up with the messenger or no there's actually
something wrong with the sprinkler would love if
there's nothing to this it's just like regular
domestic D I thought he was being signaled come
out did Marlo tell you she was running from an
ex-boyfriend she lied to you why would she do
that why don't you call her out here and ask
her yourself cuz right now I have a colleague in
the car playing online games with Jane to keep the
kid busy if you don't get Marlo out here I'll go
in and get her myself but there'd be a whole lot
of screaming and caring on him I'd like to avoid
traumatizing her daughter if possible sure I won't
do it OD Donald switch blade I just love how much
more just he's cutting through all the [__] this
season it's good intimidation tactic this is a
very specific what is he doing homemade silencer
wow call Marlo out here I'll shoot you in the
leg scream I shoot you in the head how silent
is that going to make it silent enough where won't
alert other people can you come out here for a sec
can't believe you fell for that it's a 16th inch
of plastic yeah what it going to do but regular
silences are already still loud you smiled and
gave me an address where a bunch of thugs were
about to take us out either you're a Chomp or you
gladly threw us into the lion's den when you found
out we took out your guys you skipped town and
used Chad here as a human shield can I just say
shut up chading Chad shut it our head of security
got spooked when you guys came around asking
question questions he told me to give you that
address oh so now Langston's in charge not Tony
Swan no he's the one trying to stop all this hey
you would know he'd never be involved in something
like this some of us do and he'd also never listen
to Hendrick I hired Swan jammed him onto lon's
security team because the new age of security team
was incestuous yeah so you trusted Swan and I like
to think that he trusted me too that's why he came
to me when he found something suspicious is going
on little wing fly on everything except how you
fit into all this well I didn't fit into it not
until Swan came to me huh what realized that chips
being uploaded with the little wing software were
being flagged as defective in numbers outside
normal margin of error yeah management wanted to
fulfill the little wing contract on time and since
the majority of the chips tested fine we chocked
it up to a processing error and kept cranking out
product sure any idea who in engineering could
have been involved there's scores of Engineers
there's no way to know that was actually really
cool used to flashback these chips that were being
marked as defective 650 of them that sounds right
yeah buddy I told Swan to report his findings to
Langston because I didn't know he was involved
at the time but he wanted to do some more digging
he said that he was going to bring in some of his
trusted Army friends to help oh got it did swan
ever report back about what they dug up I never
heard from him again he just disappeared he's
in hiding not necessarily you signing off and
shipments as recently as yesterday he's alive or
someone signing for him some stuff still doesn't
make sense though Langston is vicious he was a
detective for over 20 years and he helped some
very unsavory people avoid jail time just so
he could keep them in his back pocket I mean
like a a biker game took care of them in Boston
professional Hitmen Brooklyn cemetery and a lot
of General Lo Lives who would take someone
out for a few bucks buried in Atlantic City
you don't mess with the 110 damn good editing
a rhythm here man yeah after two of you came
around asking questions I was afraid Langston
would see me as a potential liability there's
just great seamwork in this whole episode we're
looking for someone who recently hijacked a truck
Lotus Sams how complicated is it to install the
littlewing chips into him he'd need his engineer
to demonstrate but after that he'd be fine on
his own be nice to know who his engineer is you
just have to ask linkston we will engineer summer
results maybe L has been hiring people and saying
and disguising himself under the name of the
Alias of so that way yeah people the the army
people will one time will think it's Swan could be
maybe L smarter than we think he is fire will be
landing soon and he's not going to hand over
a penny unless he knows how to install those
chips fire those weapons like he's rolling out of
bed won't be a problem I will hold his hand and
we'll guide him through the steps I'll kiss him
good night afterwards those two women who came
by asking about copian they brought a couple of
friends to track me down they threatened me and
my daughter and what did you tell them a bunch
of Lies they're going to figure that out sooner
or later and when they do I am terrified they're
going to come back for us screed the shadows and
if you did what I said you make a lot of money
and nothing would happen to you and Janie now
I'm a man of my word I can keep you both safe
clearly I I mean calling from a deli I I think
they're following me so I I have to keep moving
okay okay where could we meet he wants to kill her
he's going to do it himself don't die don't die
yeah you got one job man and making house calls
now only when shit's about to go down Jack doctor
we're luring Langston in to take him out get this
[__] I got a different job for you she works
for new age she and her daughter on Langston's
loose end list Marlo's The Lure need someone to
watch the kid I need my whole team that leaves
you I saw what you did for Mikey in the cemetery
I know you do the same for Jane yeah you got a
heart man and I also play Nintendo switch over
here he I cornered Marsh and he cop to being on
Langston's payroll told me to get with the program
and I told him the off and I took the money of
course I'm going to my cousin's house on Stan
Island for a day or two just in case I'll bring
the girl with me no one go find you on St Island
I love how dark Darkly lit this episode is but
it but this it still is very striking I don't
need no handicapp and pal trust me I bet you
don't oh respector I'm going to be back soon
everything's going to be okay I promise right
you have your Nintendo switch you have your
character tra with you do you remember your
Gamertag you're going to listen to my voice and
you're going to run when I tell you to run we
clear on that whoa cool shot soon as you're gone
we're going to come up behind him and block the
exit odonald and Dixon will box him in yeah
this episode so far is the most personality
and style to the Direction real mood here
thought the last one did too but this one
especially suspenseful stalking angles yeah
this is a really good episode yeah I love
this this is a really really good episode
this has the perfect blend of the tone I
loved the first time around but all the new
elements of the Season you're going to like
Staten Island stop by doas get a chick
and cutless Sandu maybe watch an Adam
Sandler movie or something feel like
something terrible is going to happen
be back with your mom and yeah please don't
they got to have that fight yeah damn it no
no no no but he can see it he can see get in
the back and keep your head down Chase let's
go Ram it come on a certain spot the certain
spot of the front of the car I thought it
would bring it back oh Jesus oh he got one of
those like just stay down automatic pistols D
was an intense ass episode hey they tracked
us down Marsh or Langston I don't know and
I don't give this [__] it's Russo we got
to go wait what's wrong who the hell is she
talking to no no no no no God damn it oh no
oh [__] Jack just running right into the
action
w great drive the bus this is a really well done
episode holy [__] this is easily the
best one yet it's like it's a constant
build just get more into the shadows
as we go yeah yeah you're in the gritty
underbelly feel feel the environment
feel the weather yeah the squelch
underfoot come on get in
nice that's probably theil
yep as a hero sh just got decar they
found Russo we got to go oh what are
you doing get in go find Jane I'm not done
here I'm staying with Richard you're not
done here Russo's outmanned out gun
and has a kid with him you all need
to go sh get down oh get down ow ni CH o
what a great shot what a great shot holy
[__] damn this is so well composed I'm heading
east keep heading towards Queen going
to intercept oh just Ram right into
him there you go God damn no one ever
thinks to just shoot the damn tires thank
you steal one of these buses oh oh great
silhouette like a Michael Myers shot or
something oh now we're in the perspective of
them trying to hunt him down he's the villain to
them oo damn he's in a he's just in a choking
mood this season choker ch squeeze that truth
out Jack Jack truther killer and him's
coming out like it's not just the not
the soldier but the killer yeah he's
letting some of that rage and grief
out just going to let lure them into
this one bu one at a time it's like
a video game take it a slow boy
all the NPCs coming in one at a
time god oh my god dude dude guy's
head's going to come off third guy
in the butt let's go now we just
need Robert Patrick we got the
whole set oh man I just wanted him
to come back in yeah the same scene
[Music]
again nice dude there's also an excellent use
of the sound is on on the editing of knowing
went to like really utilize the weather and
the thunderstorms they cut to just silence
yeah and even like the way they cut in the
middle of that scream you just hear it from
far away I love like the Silhouettes the breath
yeah good thing the roads are empty here in New
York uhoh uhoh no no you okay okay I'm going
move to like come and get you oh no dude no
don't die do not die I will accept a heroic
wounding and that is all what if Rosco just
shows up I would love that so much fley told
me what was going on I'm here to help place
is surrounded by barbwire fence there's only
one exit you got to get past me to reach it
reach a [__] a helicopter please
don't tell me they're going to like
lay down ladder or some [__] W great
shot I what is this episode yeah Jesus
damn Jack can grab the tail and pull it out of the
sky this is like video game symmetry
man God an air lift out Jesus Christ man
look how bold this Jack Reacher is I know
he's just walking right out into it jeez
again just the Shadows the gun
flare ah so excellently used this
is a beautifully shot episode
come on man talk about your dad
flashback God come on get behind the T come on
how many Clips did you bring with you when I say
so you run as fast as you can I can yes you can I
promise I won't let anything happen to you I want
you to run down that way and whatever you do don't
look back Jack Richard don't look back he never
look back never look back come on ready I think NY
just got to smash into the bad guys I sure hope so
needs some sense of relief right now but give us
a cliffhanger when he gets shot yeah of course
damn he just going head on yeah he's he's going
like a hero no come on G damn it this cannot no
no oh get in there Marlo's daughter yeah go
kick the last guy's ass it's not always Fair
kid yeah and that girl was forever traumatized
yep call 911 copy [Music] that I'm going be real
upset if he's dead if he's going to die
girl she's okay she's safe damn it oh no
no what the hell he's great God damn it oh man
no hold on man hold on man ambulance is on its
way oh for the love of God please please be in
time if he just waited like 30 more [Music]
seconds of course and on the
sirens just had to wait like 30 more seconds
I know if there was one time I would have
welcomed a little bit of Hollywood
movie Magic timing it would have been
then D ah damn damn that hurts damn it damn it
Jack should have saved him oh I just want to just
want to bask in the vibe of this episode there's
no time because you got to go to a party so yes I
gotta go got to keep this one efficient today yes
so no shouting out shirts oh but I love the shirts
I know I'm wearing one right now uh we're in
January right now December was our most successful
month hey ever thank you guys thank you and a
lot of the sales actually came after Christmas
which surprised me so thank you get those new
year gifts new year new te people thought they
were like some after Christmas special S no n
just exactly what they you haven't been around
that long they do some of hey maybe that can be
a new thing is we'll just do a sale after all
the normal sales um but yeah no I I love those
shirts just ordered even more for me half the
sales came for my own credit card yeah constantly
buying more and more like the guy who joins the
the network marketing company and just keeps
buying product for himself to climb the ladder
never succeeding actually but always getting those
numbers uh yeah I mean we if you're listening to
us on Apple and Spotify we just watched Reacher uh
season 2 episode 6 and whilst we have been on a a
journey with this particular season and it it was
a little bit up and down I know for many people it
was already like a solid like nope this is great
right away and for us it wasn't quite that in the
beginning and then by four I was like oh this is
really starting a dve with me five I thought was
really good and this was like wow this was I'm
loving this season phenomenal and it's I just
paused this by accident on Director of Photography
Bernard Couture and we don't often shout out the
DPS on these shows like their named specifically
and I'm glad I accidentally paus it here because
the cinematography on this episode was phenomenal
I thought it was absolutely excellent it was like
the number one thing I was commenting on uh while
we were watching it because you know like we have
often uh talked about the distinguishable
differences between what season 1 did and
what season 2 did and I think that this episode
uh kind of um made it all sort of emblematic of
what the season was sort of building to in terms
of its uh aesthetic and voice of what it wanted
to encapsulate because you're cutting around
between Colorado and New York primarily two
very cold areas one's a busy bustling City and the
other is uh not quite that it's more naturistic
aline as we're seeing it here yeah yeah yeah and
uh there's the main Spots You're cut in between
other than like flashbacks and here uh I I thought
they really captured like season one's very uh you
know uh grimy and what's a word that you use like
what's a John word that you use uh season one is
is both like grimy but it's also got like a lot
of air to it like it's got a lot of it's got that
swampy Southern Gothic flare yeah it's got a lot
of breath in atmosphere and so does and this one
does too but it's much more cold and for lack
of a better word but they and that's something
that I've been saying that I really wish that they
would um really cap capitalize on and I felt like
they were kind of just doing that more and more
as the season has been progressing and this one
really brought it to that point where it's like
this is they're in the darkness not just with the
with the characters this is mainly in the dark
so much of this is shot in the shadows but the
way they allow other elements around them via
NightLight stuff to illuminate uh certain seam
work whether they be gun flares or just lights
descending from lampost or whatever uh city lights
and car lights there's a lot that they've been
using to uh to just uh enhance the experience
of it but then the breath that everyone's feeling
and you could feel the coldness whereas the last
one last season you can feel the the heat of it
all yeah you're trading hot and sticky for damp
and cold yeah and I freaking love it like I just I
just love the commit like to me I'm I'm very much
when people talk about atmosphere um the thing
I'm always kind of uh that's often like a mood
rone and and to me I'm I'm big on uh feeling the
environment yeah and uh the weather and I and I
think that was such a flavor of last season and
then here you're getting the the the counter to
that uh but it feels very complimentary with all
the characters you have and then having to but
then yeah when especially there's something to
me about when you see the breath I think that's
something that can often be overlooked but I like
seeing like these actors really shot the [__]
in the cold you know yeah when you can tell that
it's real fog breath and not like CG fog breath
yeah totally like another show we were watching
I can't imagine what show you could be talking
about yeah yeah no I I agree with everything
you've said here like this this was the one that
really clicked together everything that this new
season is doing but with some of the qualitative
flourishes I loved so much that endeared me so
heavily to the first season and yeah like I love
the way that this episode breathed I love the way
it drew tension and mystery and you know just the
I think the amount of characters the amount of
you know players in this big you know mination
that's going on with little wi and new age and all
that stuff like it felt proportioned in a really
nice way here and yeah we got a bunch of really
quality scenes that sung based on acting and
just everything we know up until now it rewards
you for keeping track of the details but also
we got just some really top-notch performances in
these interrogation moments or like you know when
they're uh luring out and trying to talk to Marlo
in the house and then Russo goes and talks to that
other guy who's on the take who's you know been
involved with all this mess that they've you know
been dealing with and everything and just those
moments where you catch yourself and you're like
oh man this we've not cut away from this like
we're just letting the acting and the and the
breath of the scene and the room kind of carry all
this and and there was that that kind of humorous
moment of like you comment like oh I love that
this Chase is unfolding without music and the
music kicks in but there are a number of moments
throughout this where I think yeah they did trust
just the environment and the real tension of just
being in the situation and how loud just silence
and ambient noise can get when you know you're
in some kind of intense altercation and I think
this episode had a really terrific grip on that
that elevated so many different scenes even the
one brief moment where we check in with am was
appropriately sort of like harsh and Sinister
for what it was and you felt the cold and you
felt the sort of sad you know poetic Injustice
of of how he just like took out this cop cold and
and just moves on and uh and yeah it's like all
the little details are great and you know we
get a little bit of catharsis with Dixon and
Jack and I'm still terrified that you're going
to be right especially because we're moving into
the point where Swan is now perhaps uh going to
prove to be on the right side of things and you
know prove that Jack's Faith you know is good but
then you know maybe they'll come in I don't know
I I can't tell if it's going to be that his uh you
know judgment is sound all the way through and you
know the suspicions with Dixon will be unfounded
but also I know how Drama Works and that would
be a hell of a you know knife to stick in our
side as viewers she is a villain she's really
committed to the ACT murdering a lot of langens
people yeah well you know really sometimes being
a double agent is hard you got to do some uh
unsavory choices to sell your uh your cover um
yeah yeah I completely Echo that because while
you got some scenes that are a little bit more
direct in terms of its emotionality like with um
oh my God what's cop's name Russo Russo and his
captain yeah chief of police I I don't know I got
a Serpico yeah well no I mean Serpico is is Russo
because he doesn't he's no snitch he the envelope
that's that's what a Serpico is yeah have you not
seen C it's been a long time I've seen the Co the
whole thing is he's not a or maybe it was Caro's
way there was a period of time where you were
lending me all these Pacino movies serpo man so
I should probably watch Serpico again Serpico
serpo reaction baby's great all no Serpico is
the Frank suro was a real guy who refused to be
on the take that's cool and when everyone was on
the take and uh that is and then in the in the
70s that was like a really big thing and then he
exposed a lot and he was shunned oh man it was a
whole whole ordeal and uh and he had a big beard
a great big bushy beard that's that his main main
trait is he looked like a total hippie yeah he had
a beard and integrity um what's funny about the
movie though is they shot it backwards because to
to make because he he grows the beard over time
in the movie and he starts off with no hair and
he goes and they had to shoot it they actually had
to shoot it backwards they started with the most
crazy a hard acting job work the entire thing
backwards got to hope that you got everything
you needed when your beard was that long so
strange anyway um the but yeah like with that
scene between him and the CH police that was great
uh scene workor where that was more direct about
the the emotions of of uh what they represent
here and like how they come from like the dad
was the the dad was like probably like the Serpico
would not not deal with anything dirty and then he
he was surrounded by the amount of crookedness
and stuff but a lot of it rooted in fearness by
going up against the fear going up against uh
the threats and the Manpower and stuff so that
was more direct but then when you got like scenes
such as the interrogation moment with Jack Chad
and Margo Marlo um them where that's a little
bit more plot heavy uh and a lot of expositional
[__] what they do so good at is still capturing
the fear that like Marlo's experiencing and the
intensity and uh the determination behind what
Jack and Company are are after as well so even
though there are scenes that could still just
be like sometimes the plot Exposition back and
forth scenes can just feel that way you know
just like Bam Bam Bam Rhythm and then here
this episode they really gave us scenes that were
uh beyond that they were they would they would do
that but they knew to ground it in some type of
immediate emotion that even if you're not fully
keeping up with all the the [__] they're saying
that you're still latched onto the emotion the of
the scene you know and that's the most important
thing and that was kind of what was missing for me
in some of the other earlier episodes I'm like
yeah there's a lot of back and forth there's a
lot of scenes you got to build to it I get it um
that's a good observation though cuz that's what
tempers I think yeah in the first few episodes
I was like okay we got a lot of details and we
got a lot of people and we got a lot of history
that's been told to us but like to get to the
point where we can have the emotional moments
that can transcend all that and just form the
attachment between viewer and characters yeah you
know that was the stuff that yeah I was hoping for
more of that that has only grown as the season has
gone on and was the best it's been I think in this
episode yeah and I I loved uh I love alen Rich's
performance this season around because there's
so much uh you could you can feel the worry in
him that is like rising to the surface just in
his eyes alone I think he's doing an excellent job
and I I think the guy plays Russo is great it's a
fascin because it could have easily just been like
another Rosco situ not Rosco NE um Finley Finley
it's another Finley situation and while there's
like some dynamics that you can sort of compare
it's not the same thing and and I really do like
that guy and I'm hoping that they're just doing
some like ending scene where yeah he's dead and
then he comes back he's in the hospital healing
or some [__] you know I could see it going both
ways with this show but this is an instance where
I would be like oh yeah please just like let
him be alive deserves a shot to live I think
yeah uh but it would be heartbreaking and and and
very effective cuz I think he gives an excellent
excellent performance and I like seeing the way
how certain seeds were planted that you kind of
just feel like are passway information that
eventually come back around little girl being
gamer um you know uh Russo talking with the kid at
the at the funeral yeah these little things that
uh do ultimately factor into the bigger picture of
the Season or to a later episode uh I really like
cuz sometimes these things happen in an episode
and then they kind of just happen and you don't
really know what the point of it is and then they
come back into like a later episode yeah it's like
a function of like oh look he's nice to kids but
like it says something about him in the previous
episode and then it yeah it sets up this natural
you know reason that he would initially be taken a
back but also like yeah okay I can watch this kid
um and on top of that too uh I just love how much
of a bulldozer Jack is this time around you know
like there was that one episode in last season
where he was a oneman army but he was like I'm
going to put on my makeup I'm going to prepare my
knives Aquarian I going to do everything and then
here when the when Marlo's just in the middle of
about to get shot he just runs in start shooting
he like everyone leave I'm G to handle this yeah
I got this I'm a tank yeah uh me just use my
environment uh and yeah this is a top of just
great scenes throughout even if we didn't get like
the action scenes that was just like the cherry on
top and I just thought it built to the finale very
well where every scene felt like before it's been
like a political it's been a political thriller
and this brought it to a more tangible Prime drama
yeah you know and to that makes it more personal
when you that genre in particular I personally
find to be more personal and intimate and that
that's what it I think it I think that you know
what now I think about it I feel like uh that was
the ingredient Secret Sauce to uh season 1 uh was
was that's a crime drama yeah you know it's not
really a political like there's polit it really
felt like crime drama a first political thrill
or second and then this felt like the inverse
where like political thriller first crime drama
political thriller crime procedural and the drama
yeah kicks in later and that's the thing you
don't want it to just feel like a procedural
yeah uh I thought this was freaking awesome
it was it was really cool love this episode
The Action was really cool too yeah it was really
really cool action dudes are going in the bus and
he's just murking him and and yeah like you said
the the Shadows the way they use the lighting the
way they really make it feel dark and cold and
D and scuzzy and yeah scuzzy was the word I was
looking for yeah it's really nicely it's nicely
handled in a way that's that is really effective
but it's not like in your face at the same time
like it's a it's yeah it's really nicely Chosen
and even when they pull out some weird lens or
something it's always like well chosen here yeah
yeah there's there's a lot of shots are that I
think could be very overlooked uh oh yeah like
I I love the shot with the helicopter descending
and Jack running away and yeah there's a lot of
just really well-composed shots where like damn
this took a lot of thought and only thing that
kind of distracted me is when they're run this
city streets and it's just completely vacant
you're not a movie you're a show fact that you're
doing this with such clean cinematography like
you're not relying on a bunch of Wild Cuts Like
like you could really keep up the camera looks
really locked on and it's not uh it's not going
all hand hell then and like cut cut cut cut cut
to mask your your lack of space you had to work
with I'll take car stunts and actual Chase over
vehicle extras yeah it's like if I got a trade
I'll take that yeah there's so much you can do
um but yeah I mean overall but yeah that was
that this was a really great episode um this
this was truly a a great episode looking forward
to the next two right two more two more I think
all right we'll knock it out the park guys thank
you so much for being here um if you're listening
us Apple Spotify please write this video
and thank you everyone who's been on this
journey with Reacher with us and we will catch
you all soon thank you very much [Music] bye